I've just had an audience with her  majesty the queen following the  dissolution of Parliament the general  election will be held on may the seven  the next prime minister walking through  that door will be mean or ed miliband  there are two futures on offer at this  election to carry on with the  conservative plan or a Labour plan a  better plan you can choose an economy  that grows or you can choose the  economic chaos of Ed Miliband this has  been a historic government the very last  thing that the country now needs is a  lurch to the left or the right that we  have become the most eclectic diverse  political party you know we are a quite  reflective of it now as a party of what  modern Britain make really for me  there's only one choice and I choose  we want to make Scotland voice haired we  want to make sure that big team of SMP  MPs and performance to stand up for  Scotland thank you  you